Hello, hi everybody.
We are now live.
We're going to wait for some people to join.
Hello everybody. Good afternoon or good morning or good night
depends on where you are joining from.
Why don't you tell us a little bit about where you're joining from? Hi.
Hello.
While I join, while I ask her,
oh, from Brussels.
Let's see if Alina can join.
Hello from Croatia. Hi.
Hello. Hi.
Hello, Alina.
How are you Alina?
I'm good. You hear me exactly?
Yes, we can hear you.
So for everybody to know, this is a little bit of a different live. Um,
I'm going to give a short introduction
and that he was going to tell us a little bit of her project
because two years ago Russian forces invaded Ukraine and when Russia
uh, started this unprecedented and this illegal war against Ukraine,
The European Union
and its allies made the collective decision to support Ukraine.
This comes, uh,
the support comes in many forms
and one of them is why arenas near with us is uh,
through education and youth projects.
So one of these projects is called uh,
Youth Media Sharks and we're speaking to Adina Sultanova
who will tell us a little bit about the project.
So hi, how are you?
You know, all good.
I'm good. Yeah,
thank you. Could you introduce yourself a little bit to us?
Hey, yes, sure.
My name is Arina. I'm 21.
Uh, I'm from sumo.
It's a very beautiful City in Ukraine. Uh,
I'm studied at Sumo State University at Bachelor of degree
and I'm studying journalism and Public Relations
and uh I'm had been had been working uh
science like 16 years in this area in journalism
and after continue to work in
in a city console in our city in the press center
and like a hobby I like to write different scientific docs and
and like and as a part
I like playing different music instruments
and taking part in Erasmus Project 2.
Good good.
Nice to meet you. Yes.
Um, I wanted to tell
to ask you a little bit about the project that you're involved in um,
tell us what is the main purpose of this of this project
what are the goals?
Alright, it was a really amazing project uh,
it's names Yasmida Sharks made the literacy up skillin uh
it's project like promotion uh
made that literacy and critical critical thinking and uh
it was really amazing project because um uh
in this project the main goal is like uh
do uh like
understanding how working this information and propaganda
and tell about it to yes person
and we did it I want to tell about like a steps our project firstly
like we have two groups
it's like Ukrainian groups and group and Portuguese group
and we working together in our cities
and first if you like have a training about media literacy
information propaganda
and the second step if you Like analyse our local media and uh see uh
use the disinformation propaganda or no because it's like important uh
because nowadays we have a lot of disinformation uh
good example it's like about Covid 19
and now which connected topic with us is like
who's care Russian
Ukrainian bar and after this
we like create
like a recommendation and show it to our stakeholders in our cities
and after with our like ideas
we flight to beautiful island Madeira and like we have a training
have a course of training to a different schools
and it was really useful to them and to us too
and after this we like uh with like Portugal guys creates uh website
uh you can uh like write in internet yes
major sharks that's l and find our like sticker box
posters and different things about this information
which can help you like to know more about it and you can use
young people can use it
and to social media and to Zen's communication
and it's like about our project yeah,
we will be giving more information on the project
the coming weeks and any questions
you can always DM us
but we've already so we've spoken about the project
the goals of the projects
I want to hear about you.
So what significance does this project hold for you?
We can kind of get an idea but personally how do you feel about this?
Uh I think uh
it was a Really amazing project
and it's very important for me because firstly
it was my first Erasmus project. Uh,
secondly, it's topic really like clear uh,
me obviously it's connected with me
with my specialty because I'm like a journalist and I need to
to know more about this information and as it seems
and certainly it's like important for us because now know this
a lot of disinformation about our war in our country
and old people
and young people need to understand how to identify fake news
and good news and it's for me, uh,
firstly I remember that in that time when I was in Madeira
we had uh um
blackout in our country and we really worried about it in that time
but like we was in safety and we really thanks for supporting for us.
Thanks Portuguese guys for supporting for us.
We feel it's uh is it time and it's very important for us.
Of course, of course.
I it's
it's great to I mean I I don't have anything obviously to add to that
um, and it's it's great that that you're
you've been able to live that I'm so we've spoken about the past
we are talking about the present
because you will be presenting the results of this project
but I wanted to hear a little bit of the future of your expectations
and uh
what outcomes do you expect from the project
not only personally but also for the broader community? Yes,
I think we have a really good results of this project
we have like it's like our achievement and now
now we like popularize it this project,
this results to young people and and give like this recommendation
give our results to young people in our
like cities and in organization
which work working out with young people
and I think and we
with Portugal groups
like continue to our like working business project and maybe continue
create something that's I'm
and that's great. That really is um,
we are very much looking forward to seeing this project evolve
and I wanted to thank you,
you, you really are an inspiration.
I mean, not only the project,
but you are an inspiration to all of us and
and I wanted to thank you
and thank everybody who has joined and is joining now also, um,
if you have any questions,
please come to us. We will be having other lives related to
other projects that are funded by European Solidarity
Core and Erasmus plus and uh,
we just wanted to say thank you.
Uh, Europe will stand with Ukraine every step of the way.
So stay tuned. And again,
thank you for joining. Yes,
I want to send YouTube to send Erasmus
to send our organisators of different Erasmus project
because for example, now I continue
I take part in an Erasmus project
and now and tomorrow we'll go to another Erasmus project.
It's really important for us.
Thank You for your support.
Thank you. Thank you for being there.
And thank you to the rest.
Have a great day. Have a great day, too.
Bye. Bye. Bye.